Let's try to build up some intuition about the inverses of exponential
functions. Let's use f of x equals 2 to the x as an example to play with. We're
going to think about how the input and outputs of this function, and its
inverse, are related. So, here's the graph of f of x equals 2 to the x. Just
like you've seen many times before. And then reflected in the line y equals x,
we see its inverse, which for now we're just calling f inverse of x. We know
that if we input 3 to the function f, we'll get the output 8, and that means
that if we input 8 into the function f inverse, We'll get an output of 3. We
know this, because we know that x and y has switched position in our inverse
functions. To find out more about our functions, f and f inverse, I'd like you
to fill out this table. For each value over here, fill in the corresponding
value over here. These are inputs of f, and these are outputs of f. Which means
these are outputs of f inverse, and these should be inputs of f inverse.